hey what's going on is filburn it's time
for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday February 20th 2017 what's going
on Hawaii I am recording off of my
laptop if this sounds a little bizarre
I'm in New York City came in time to do
the the Patrice O'Neal benefit the fifth
annual Patrice O'Neal benefit that's
gonna be going down tomorrow night at
the New York City Center and it should
be a great time as you can tell I'm a
little jet-lagged
I took a [ __ ] red-eye last night and
there was this lady no it's hilarious
it's when you have a kid if you actually
go on the road the big thing when you go
on the road now is not you know not the
booze not the cigars not hanging out
with your friends it becomes like holy
[ __ ] I'm gonna get eight hours of
uninterrupted sleep so I get on the
plane and this woman not in my row but
the next row over she had a little baby
and it was crying and then dude next to
me fell asleep and started snoring and I
just started laughing and the poor woman
like she was traveling alone with this
baby right I mean it was a baby - maybe
a little bit older than mine I'm my
first kid so I can't judge I don't know
if this kid was - three months I don't
know if it was 26 years old and had that
disease that that [ __ ] baby had in
the Brad Pitt movie remember that
remember the old baby was just hanging
around and you know that guy wanted to
like bang the chick and he's like you
got to get this old baby out of here cuz
it's weirding me out
what you know I'd like to think that
that guy later on once his dick wasn't
hard and he was thinking clearly again
he probably was thinking yeah now I
probably should have said that you know
I probably shouldn't trash that old baby
that was the name of a band I used to
play an old baby and you know we got a
record contract and everything
you know lead singer got an appendicitis
I don't what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
um anyway so the baby's [ __ ] crying
and the poor woman like she falls asleep
and the baby's like freaking out
screamin and she can't hear because
she's like she's [ __ ] exhaustion
she's got a baby she's flying with it so
and I'm sitting there and I'm watching
the thing squirming around in her hands
are like not really holding it anymore
so now it's like this situation like is
this is this lady gonna drop that
[ __ ] baby
so I'm staring over there I'm sure other
people will look at it me thinking I was
giving her the evil eye cuz a baby was
crying but I wasn't I was just I don't
know what the [ __ ] I thought it was
gonna do cuz I still had my seatbelt on
my safety first then of babies see that
that's why I'll never be a hero because
what a true hero does is he sees danger
and without any sort of self a nice and
he's safe you know what I mean that's to
me as a hero like in fury if you're in a
[ __ ] bank right and these guys come
in with guns and they go to rob the
place and they said we're gonna plug but
he's [ __ ] brains up and then you act
on that you're not really a hero to me
okay because at no point in that
scenario were you safe alright you were
immediately in the situation so no
matter how you slice it no matter how
many [ __ ] people you saved at the end
of the day you were motivated to save
your own ass and everybody else getting
saved along with you is you know this is
just collateral damage that means
positive but if you're outside the bank
you like holy [ __ ] I'm out here I'm
eating the bacon bacon egg and cheese
sandwich you know getting ready to go
for a run you know fuel myself up you
stretching your [ __ ] hammies that all
of a sudden you see you I don't know you
look at one of those [ __ ] giant Bank
windows you see a robbery going down and
then you go in there with you Larry Bird
short shorts right
they'd [ __ ] try to stop the rock then
to me yeah that's like you and me you
know they dislike the Hall of Fame and
then there's also you know people
literally have like their own wing of a
Hall of Fame
yeah to me that's like you know that's
when you get to your own way but if
you're already in the [ __ ] I don't can't
even what the [ __ ] I was talking about
the eletric yeah okay not a hero right
so I finally sort of flagged down the
stewardess and she goes yes you know
what can I get you and I said I think
what I have to [ __ ] that I say I said I
said can that baby fall and she started
laughing because she thought I was being
sarcastic like I was upset with the baby
crying and she thought I meant like and
that baby fall on the ground and shut
the [ __ ] up and she was like taken aback
but she also laughed which to me
immediately made her really cool that
she could laugh thinking that some guy
was just being sarcastic being like in
that baby please fall on the [ __ ]
floor of an airplane knock itself out so
I can get some sleep and I was like no
no no no no I mean I was I'm concerned
that it's gonna fall so she kind of went
over there to make sure the baby was
alright but um I don't know I'm a
changed man my urge was to go over and
hold the baby what's happened to me
becoming a [ __ ] softy you know
actually you know I told you before I
never got mad at babies crying on
airplanes because I always felt they
would they were just expressing exactly
what I was feeling
there's no way to get on an airplane and
at some point you know and unless you're
going on some [ __ ] great vacation but
if you're getting on there and you know
you're going back to see the relatives
or it's some business trip or something
like that you know then you just see
some wide-body coming down the [ __ ]
aisle and you're praying to God first
it's not gonna sit next to you but you
know they're gonna you know something's
gonna [ __ ] it happen it'd probably be
really good for you for your life
expectancy if you had access to your
emotions that you could just break down
right god I would love to skim actually
get on a [ __ ] plane and there was
just the 300 adults in there just crying
like babies yeah probably a nightmare
but there's a part of me would think
that that was awesome anyways I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about so
I I'm telling this [ __ ] story in the
wrong way I actually yesterday I did I
presented at a Hollywood Awards Show old
freckles the big [ __ ] phony himself
when all Hollywood rented a tuxedo
shoutout to mr. tux on Wilshire
Boulevard wasn't gonna say yeah I had to
I had to do the present thing and I just
sort of wrote something and I quickly
when I got to the writers guilt thing I
immediately was like wow I should have
not just written what I'm gonna say once
I should have gone over this a bunch of
times so I just was kind of going over
it in my [ __ ] head and you know I
thought it was just gonna be a bunch of
writers but there was some like actors
there and [ __ ] like Denzel was there and
uh who's the other guy that James Woods
it was a light animal there was like
serious [ __ ] people there the thing
was when you go up in front of a bunch
of writers like no matter what they've
accomplished you don't know what they
look like so you can't get nervous like
someone could literally have been
sitting there and they wrote the Best
Picture Oscar winner [ __ ] nine years
in a row or nine years I'd know what
they look like for whatever you know
they could accomplish [ __ ] like that you
have no [ __ ] idea what they like for
the whole night they were just pulling
people out of the crowd and I love you
said they're going I don't know who this
guy is and then when they would say what
the [ __ ] they did I was like Jesus
Christ so with every person they pulled
out of the crowd like I don't know I
just felt like the pressure was getting
more and more and I just kept muttering
to myself this is it this is it one and
done I'm never doing one of these
[ __ ] things again this is not this is
not my
my thing I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing here this is stupid
these people are smart they're
accomplished like like this [ __ ] that
you know some of the [ __ ] people in
the crowd the stuff that they do you
know what it takes to write a movie and
actually get it made and then get that
[ __ ] giant rock
up the [ __ ] hill as opposed to make
who just say is it T's a [ __ ] joke I
think I'll try this you know is I'm
riding over on the subway to a club I
don't know I just kept getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and Patton Oswalt
hosted it [ __ ] murder this monologue
was great his model it was so great I
kind of forgot that I had to go up I was
just sitting there was a fan enjoying
for an hour Burson was there and he went
out and somehow gave his credit-card
information that's what he did before he
said the nominees and somehow we made
that [ __ ] hilarious and once again it
just made me feel like why am I here I
shouldn't be here so I'm finally waiting
to go up and James Woods is giving some
sort of Lifetime Achievement Award to
Oliver Stone thank god this [ __ ] wasn't
televised which is also [ __ ] somebody
made a reference to that like nobody
works [ __ ] harder than those guys and
they won't even put it on TV because
nobody knows what they look like I guess
so he tells the whole [ __ ] story of
being best friends with Oliver Stone for
35 years and I have to go on after this
[ __ ] and I just yeah that's why I just
kept thinking I just kids kept I started
looking at my watch the way I used to
back in the day when I would do nooners
which is a stand-up expression for
basically you're doing a college gig and
the show is essentially at 12 noon or
1:00 in the afternoon it's usually in a
cafeteria and it is a [ __ ] nightmare
you go up there and you have to do an
hour you have to stand in front of just
stand in public in a cat
[ __ ] college cafeteria in front of
like God knows how many three four five
six hundred [ __ ] college students who
have no idea that there's going to be
any sort of performance forget about a
comedy show and like the level of just
[ __ ] like I don't even think it's
like it's really hard for me to be
humiliated now after you go doing enough
of those like you just get so walled off
you just you just accept it you're like
okay my life is gonna suck like it's
never sucked starting in about three
minutes however in an hour in three
minutes I'm going to be back in my
rental car and I'm never gonna see these
[ __ ] people again that's what that's
what I that's the mindset I used to go
into I used to go up there and I used to
just psych myself up to be like how hard
can I commit to these jokes how big of
an ass can I make of myself and just to
try to not give in to the horror slash
negative vibe of the situation because
if he did that I learned the hard way
you were gonna burn through an hour of
material in like 17 minutes and you were
gonna be angry and your agent was gonna
get a call so anyways James Woods is
going on and on and on he brings up
[ __ ] I don't mean that a bad way
it's just said Oliver Stone has
accomplished so many things and all her
stone goes up there and after a night of
[ __ ] trunk bashing just so eloquently
stated that all the countries we've
invaded all of the stuff that we've done
and he said during all of our history of
doing this there's been both Democrats
and Republicans holding the office of
president I thought it should have got
more than applause break but you know I
don't know the Trump thing is just such
low-hanging fruit at some points like we
get it Hollywood does not like Trump
having said
this [ __ ] guy went onstage and did
the best Trump I should have gotten his
name I was so [ __ ] nervous for what I
had to do he did the best Trump
impression
I [ __ ] nuanced performance that he
did it just it was unbelievable and then
he did a lot of really really [ __ ]
harsh jokes like even like writers they
sit in [ __ ] writers room you wouldn't
think that you could get them to pull
back it's just because they were in
public and he just totally [ __ ]
committed so I got kind of inspired by
that so long story short I'm sitting
there waiting to go on and they
mentioned that Oliver Stone I guess
wrote Scarface which I didn't know and I
remember my mother took us to go see
that my youngest brother was nine at the
time so I thought that was pretty cool
so I just went out there and I sort of
winged it told the story about how I
used to think a pony was a small horse
and and I don't name I can't remember
what I said but I think it went okay and
I got off stage and I actually thought
for half a second like you know what
that was actually kind of fun and I
realized that a lot of my version to
award shows is just my own social
anxiety of not knowing how to behave
when there's a roomful of people just
saying positive [ __ ] to each other like
if that there give awards shows were
like absolute I'm not talking like
roasts I don't like roasts either I
don't know what happened to roast roast
to me used to be funny and then it just
became just like this you know
Tourette's thing yeah I wouldn't [ __ ]
you with the dog dick aids [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know it's just like Eric
so-and-so's there I'm not saying he woke
awoka-woka but this guy ba ba da ba boo
boo
I find them [ __ ] mind-numbingly
boring but whatever somewhere in-between
this summit somewhere short of that if
it was totally negative I would have
come
so I don't want the [ __ ] that says about
me so I figured out what my hang-up was
with the what I will say though I still
will never get past listening to [ __ ]
people talk politics and [ __ ] the
environmental issues in all of that [ __ ]
it's just like everybody knows we
already know this [ __ ] we already know
it you're not going to inspire anybody
like you know I kind of gave a [ __ ]
about the environment but then when that
guy from [ __ ] third Rock from the Sun
set that [ __ ] about Antarctica I was
like wait a minute this is an important
issue I don't know maybe I'm just a
negative [ __ ] I am a negative time but
I'll never be able to get I just I just
think that's just like some like it's
like the Beyonce thing you know what I
mean like I never would have thought
that somebody could like exaggerate the
magnitude of creating life but somehow
she's done it my wife gets so upset what
I may find out I mean I don't like it
really have any feelings it's just fun
to make fun of her it's her fan base
it's just so [ __ ] I don't know I was
thinking I was driving me a nuts when
she was watching the Grammys and stuff
like that first well I don't get why
does she get like for our performance
and everybody else only gets like
[ __ ] six seconds you know prove it
Bruno Mars is running around doing a
bunch of costume changes you know she
comes out dressed like a Batman villain
and [ __ ] it does like a 45 minutes set
oh yeah I think it was fair to the other
performers but you know what I gotta be
honest with you I don't think I could
name one
well bootylicious that was that's when
she was with those other two girls that
she kicked to the curb if you're in an
all-girl group or if you're in a boy
band you can at this point people have
to be so [ __ ] educated that you know
at some point there's gonna be like one
person is gonna go solo you know and be
extremely successful and the rest of you
are just gonna be sitting around
working at Staples hoping that the
person who left and is now wildly
successful as a solo artist will
eventually have a couple of [ __ ] albums
so they have to come back to you to do a
reunion tour you know what I mean like
do you think Justin Timberlake's ever
gonna do the instinct thing maybe he has
I don't [ __ ] know all I could say I
guess what I'm saying is if I was in a
boy band way back in the day and I still
had my reddish orange hair I would save
my money I'd be like you know what
someone's gonna break out I know it's
not gonna be me
[Music]
anyways how far do this podcast our yeah
I gotta check I gotta check the [ __ ]
time
hey how about [ __ ] the Boston Bruins
we are undefeated with our new coach
coach I don't even know he was in Bruce
Cassidy of Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid I already forgot his
[ __ ] name I've been so goddamn busy
hey you know what the best thing about
having a baby is dude you can watch so
much [ __ ] sports in the first three
months before they learn how to crawl
around and [ __ ] every morning it's like
my favorite like my daughter is like my
new best friend I mean I was gonna
happen anyway
sorry for the extra noise I was setting
the laptop down my daughter's my new
best friend
okay aside from the obvious that she's
my blood she's my daughter and
everything but just like on a real level
she's my best friend I probably have
watched like 20 games with her already
every morning right the lovely Nia you
know she's exhausted because she still
has to breastfeed at night well I just
have to wake up you know and change a
diaper every once in a while sorry for
the hiccups here so in the mornings I
try to give my wife like three hours at
least you know what I mean like I got it
down where if she just feeds her I can
take her and then I can have a pinch and
you know I have a buy up like I have a
little [ __ ] bottle
you know to feed her I can I can go
three hours I can keep her calm for
[ __ ] three hours while uh my wife
sleeps and all that type of stuff so
what I do is I just tape games and every
morning we come upstairs and I just put
around my chest and I just sit there and
I watch games with her and she starts to
cry you know what it is what's been
working for me you know those giant
exercise balls that people use for core
strength I just get on one of those and
I just just [ __ ] bouncing up and down
on the thing it gives them the feeling
of weightlessness or some [ __ ] and if
they start crying when you're doing the
bouncing thing cause it's killing my
[ __ ] back right I just go [ __ ]
crazy big air then they're just like you
know it makes them almost almost like
when a dog wants to kill somebody and if
you just make a loud enough noise and
they [ __ ] looks in another direction
it just they completely forget that they
wanted to kill somebody babies are like
that
look they start to cry if you get this
stomach to drop they kind of go make
this face like wall you know their eyes
get big and [ __ ] and then they just kind
of get into that five and then you slow
you just slowly get it back down to
three four repetitions back down to the
road level you have and they don't cry
and then eventually they fall asleep and
I'd you know that I got I got the
[ __ ] game on and I watched one
[ __ ] college hoop so it's going to
that Duke UNC game I've been you know
obviously started taping all the Duke
games i watch Duke Virginia I miss them
against Wake Forest yesterday but uh I
got all the rest of the year I think
they got like they got Syracuse on
Wednesday then they got University of
Miami and then Florida State and then
they play UNC again March fourth even if
you you're not a huge fan of [ __ ]
college basketball you got to watch that
one I watched Kentucky Georgia Georgia
lose another heartbreaker
I watched Wisconsin Maryland which was
[ __ ] so boring I went into my [ __ ]
DVI and I had tape UNC Virginia and I
watched that one instead and watch that
[ __ ] kid what's his name number 44 on
UNC
[ __ ] is his name its alliteration Justin
Jamison no I can't remember his [ __ ]
name am i [ __ ] sleep-deprived here
totally got into that I've been watching
the NHL and because of the all-star
break
you know the Celtics gave me a break you
know because they were on the all-star
break and I got to watch a bunch of
college [ __ ] so anyways I landed here in
New York slept the whole [ __ ] flight
had my eye mask of my earplugs and I was
all good that lady didn't drop that baby
and everything was fine
you know nobody tried to hijack the
plane everything was good and I get in
the car taking the cab right over to the
hotel and they had Trump on the radio
and it's just that [ __ ] guy man Jesus
Christ he was talking about some
terrorist thing that happened in Sweden
he goes I mean this happened in Sweden
people Sweden he'd yell suite and again
he just out like I just I cannot [ __ ]
believe I can't believe that this guy is
president and I cannot believe that he's
he's so successful at it in that he's
just implementing everything like I
didn't know you could just go around
Congress with these [ __ ] executive
orders man it's [ __ ] hilarious that
he's found yet another this guy is like
this if there's like a Hall of Fame for
finding the loophole I mean he really is
like guys he's a [ __ ] genius I just
wish he was more stable because you know
Hillary would have scared the [ __ ] out
of me in a much quieter dignified way
they're not even dignified just as far
as she knows how to give a [ __ ]
speech but I don't know I don't know
the day he stops reacting to people
saying [ __ ] about him an award shows I
think I'll feel a little more
comfortable with the fact that he's uh
you know in power this is like the most
simple and basic thought I've ever had
in my life right is they keep talking
about how the tensions you know that if
Russia was actually in communication
with Trump and Europe solved nervous
because Russia's [ __ ] doing whatever
over there and blah blah blah blah blah
and these guys are thinking this and
these guys are thinking that and I just
was thinking like hey what why doesn't
everybody just [ __ ] relax you know
and I don't mean you I don't mean me
we're just regular everybody's just
walking around you know living your life
getting a [ __ ] newspaper why don't
these [ __ ] up top why don't you just
[ __ ] relax I know this is way too so
really simplified but like I would have
no [ __ ] idea what another country was
thinking or planning to do if you
weren't yammering about it alright if
the other people on the other side
weren't yammering about what the [ __ ]
we're trying to do you know why don't we
just everybody just stays home where's
your country you [ __ ] stay there
alright I don't mean refugees I just
mean leaders in your armies just [ __ ]
state it we bring our guys back
everybody just sorts out their own [ __ ]
you know and when people come to your
country to go to your [ __ ] water park
or whatever you give them the Mickey
Mouse ears you give them you can't be
put on a show well I can't just [ __ ]
be like that you know why cuz they want
to get the [ __ ] you know it's natural
resources and money that's all the [ __ ]
it is that's all of this I don't give a
[ __ ] of all any of that goddamn rhetoric
that's why the [ __ ] they doing it not
only do is sit there scaring the [ __ ]
are you I just wish everybody could like
regular people just collectively all at
the same time be like and [ __ ] it yeah
yeah exactly [ __ ] it [ __ ] everything you
saying [ __ ] Wars [ __ ] all of this [ __ ]
if you [ __ ] rich [ __ ] have a problem
with each other why don't you sit down
at your yacht clubs and try and [ __ ]
work it out you know
play a game of seven seven [ __ ]
something stud whatever the final minor
card play whatever the [ __ ] it is he do
you know enough with the blowing up of
people and [ __ ] yeah Donna I know it's
completely oversimplified but Nike at
some time but when I think about having
mind control like that's what I think it
doing
I just yeah you know with like people
are the terrorist groups all the way to
our country start saying we're gonna go
to war it's just like yeah no you know
no we're not alrighty then and then just
see what the [ __ ] they would do I think
they would literally lose their [ __ ]
minds they wouldn't know what to do cuz
they'd just be like well now what what
am I gonna do if I'm not out there
trying to get more what am I gonna do
sit here alone with my own thoughts how
many do you think would actually take
their own lives like take that fatty
over there in North Korea I'm really in
over my head by the way if you haven't
realized that this is like Meet the
Press with no press or information it's
the same thing I'll probably get sued by
that program for ruining their format
that fat [ __ ] they're you know old softy
there it doesn't have a whisker on his
[ __ ] face like you know what I mean
like you ought to be able to grow a
[ __ ] crazy beard man you know that
that's one thing I'll have to commend
that how do you know his name Kim Jong
Il's
is that his name was it Kim Jong Il
Junior Sonny Boy
Frank Sinatra jr. whatever the [ __ ] his
name is over there like the fact that he
can't grow a beard and he still has
people scared shitless you know like
what I think it just collectively over
there everybody just be like yeah dude
we don't give a [ __ ] anymore right and
everybody just goes about their business
he still gets to live in that big
[ __ ] house but nobody listens to him
look hot like nobody will kill for him
anymore no army will do anything but he
still gets to keep the giant [ __ ]
house like how [ __ ] freaked out would
he be you know nobody really goes over
talks to him or anything so eventually
he has to come out go to like a farmers
market you know and then
you don't talk to him you force him to
acclimate himself socially you know like
anybody else would if they were the new
guy in town if I had mind control that's
what the [ __ ] I would do what I don't
know what do I I would probably do some
evil shitty King if you could control
the entire world's [ __ ] brains yeah I
don't think I could I don't think I
could handle that all right [ __ ] that I
know it's a dumb idea
all right let's let's read some let's
read some [ __ ] uh advertising here
for this week all right
wince pronounced a wink spell twin so
without the e winc all right whiskey
India November charlie finding new great
new wine is tough you know I tell you I
got to agree with these I gotta agree
with these [ __ ] people that was said
[ __ ] but I know they don't like what I
say that turn these reads I actually
agree with these guys finding good wine
is difficult it's like trying to find a
good cigar like where the [ __ ] do you
start there's so many of them there's so
many articles there's so much faith news
fake news about the cigars finding new
wine is tough that's why I've been
telling you all about our sponsor at
Club W Club to have you clam not present
anymore like to fly-fish and paint and
how they make it so easy to get wine
personalized to your palate and
delivered right to your door and here's
a little update free for you Club W is
now called wince spelt occult wink spell
winc a new name and an improved look but
here's the important part it's still the
same amazing wine company introducing
you to new wines that you love why did
he switch from club W to something that
it's really difficult to pronounce and
spell winked works directly it's not I'm
not saying it's difficult to pronounce
but like if you looked at winc I mean
you're not thinking wink what does that
stand for we incorporate no cuts but
wince works directly with wine makers
and growers from all over the world to
create delicious wines and deliver it
right to your door
100% satisfaction guaranteed means if
you don't like the bottles a bottle they
send you they'll replace it with the
bottle you love no questions asked Jesus
Christ Ernest Hemingway born a hundred
years too soon you don't get sent random
bottles way cos those personalized wine
membership that recommends wine
specifically for you based on the
results of your palate Profile quiz I
can't believe I'm such a drunk and I
haven't you haven't [ __ ] use this yet
the great thing about drinking wine is
you don't feel like a drunk you know you
actually feel like you read a book of
something you can also rate all of the
wine you receive from wink so they'll
learn about you with every order and
constantly personalize the wine they
send sign up for wink right now and gain
a median insider access to the best fine
wine from all over the world find out
for yourself why yours truly and
thousands of other satisfied wine lovers
are raving about wink well I'm doing it
cuz you're paying me the best part wink
I was offering my listeners $20 off
right now when you go to try wink calm
they'll even cover this shipping
shipping shipping think about that
you'll get fine wine personalized to
your palate delivered right to your door
try wink and get $20 off and
complimentary shipping right now when
you go to trial wink calm that's try
winc calm / / why don't they have that
with like whiskey's and scotches you
know why cuz that's that's mean that's
mean alcohol you know what I mean
I mean you've a bunch of wine what's
gonna happen you know some woman's gonna
slur around some guy he'll start crying
it's just wine right I hope this isn't
making too much noise as I'm moving this
thing around but like I can only sit in
one position for so long it's part of
getting old
alright oh look we say but to me on
these me undies order a case of wine to
do to do me undies me undies you pissed
your pants but you're fine because they
have that [ __ ] motels it'll dry up
the grapes and you'll be a pal when you
take you're not saying you did
you know I hope you drank some [ __ ]
white wine or your balls will be purple
me undies picture a picture a world
we're putting on a new pair of underwear
isn't just fresh you're stepping into a
better day so you got to take a shower
first you can't just put on a fresh pair
of underwear you got to take a shower
then you put on a fresh pair of
underwear if you combine that with a
fresh pair of socks telling you right
now your energy is gonna be crazy
like do you realize that there's this
women out there that married guys
because the first time they met him they
were wearing a fresh pair of underwear
and socks and they just felt this
amazing energy from you know and then
now they're in stuck in this lovely
loveless marriage
wondering where it all went and what
they have to understand is that like you
know ladies if you want your guide to
treat you nice okay every once in a
while you got to go out you got to make
sure you update his [ __ ] underwear in
sock drawer they'll put them in a better
mood you don't I mean you don't have to
cower in the corner anymore all right
think about it I know where it's the
first thing you put on in the last thing
you take off unless you're Matthew
McConaughey why would you settle for
anything less than the best feeling
underwear on the planet Yanni's focuses
solely on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced this
is all they [ __ ] do 24/7 my friends
at me undies I don't know you [ __ ] sent
me a few pairs a while back and now I
can't imagine wearing anything else I
wear I wear I only gave me [ __ ] two
okay and I am a man over the age of 45
which means I can't figure out the
[ __ ] Internet so even if I wanted to
order some underwear which I desperately
need to do most of my underwear is at
least from two presidents ago I'm
everything in this ad I'm the exact
person that should be getting me undies
evidently it really makes each day that
much better for the price of two
cocktails me undies will deliver your
new favorite pair of underwear right to
your doorstep better day guarantee you
try them on if they're not the most
comfortable best feeling undies you've
ever had they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free included
in the price is the sweet touch of mode
out why don't I say sweet touch and
crotch area a special fabric made with
the best-in-class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times
softer than cotton these new becausee
undies are sold exclusively on the
undies website well you enjoy free
standard shipping in the US plus Canada
and for a limited time everyone in my
audience gets 20% off their first order
but if you have but you have to go to
our special URL Mia undies comm / / with
the me undies better day guarantee you
have nothing to lose so don't wait any
longer go to me undies comm / / right
now for 20% off your first order that's
me on D dot-com / / alright
oh [ __ ] he likes everybody HELOCs your
unique no god you don't walk like
everyone else talk like everyone else to
sleep like everyone else so why is your
mattress one-size-fits-all well because
there's a basic shape of a [ __ ] human
being not to mention his size because
I'm sorry I said the wrong answer
because a truly customized mattress will
cost you five to ten thousand bucks
until now
go to hell it's liek calm answer a few
simple questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body yeah
and then you show up in the next season
of [ __ ] Westworld through the
proprietary algorithms they developed
with the help of the world's leading
economic sand biomechanic experts the
result the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on yeah and having a
robot made in your [ __ ] image hellix
customers reported 30 percent
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples that customize each side of
the mattress your mattress arrives at
your door in about a week kind of
[ __ ] they do this in a week and
shipping is a hundred percent free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about hellix
sleep you have a hundred nights to try
it out if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for free
gross and give you a hundred 100% refund
no questions asked go to HELOCs leap
comm slash bird and get $50 off your
order that's helix sleep calm / / HELOCs
sleep calm / /
all right lastly but not leastly
stamps.com avoid the hassle of the post
office and mailing everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account and minutes online with
no equipment to lease no long-term
commitments click print mail and you're
done unlike the post office stamps calm
never closes print postage for letters
or packages at your convenience 24/7
seven days a week
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
fingertips
buy and print official US postage for
any letter in any package any class of
mail using your own computer and printer
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter I use stamps comm any time
I'm setting out my [ __ ] posters
you know horn my cell phone right now
you can enjoy the Stamp service with a
special offer that includes a full week
trial plus postage and a digital scale
with long term commitments go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Bertha
stamps comm enter birth all right there
we go Jesus Christ I'm done with that
[ __ ] sorry for sitting on the [ __ ]
laptop how much time will be up to here
Oh 38 minutes
perfect it's time to start reading some
letters before I do I want to thank
everybody the night before the Patrice
O'Neal benefit for everybody that has
bought tickets once again and we've been
able to keep this benefit going and I
cannot even begin to tell you how much
this has helped his loved ones it's just
been such a great thing and his sad and
tragic as it always will be that he
passed away too soon just all you guys
stepping it up every year and seeing
like just how much that has changed and
helped the people that he was helping
out when he was alive it's just I can't
thank you enough alright okay
Friday the 13th [ __ ] oh this is um
this is in regards to I was talking
about that like why
Friday the 13th unlucky rather than
Monday the 13th so this person comes to
me with this it says bill with regards
to your podcast involving Friday the
13th
the main superstition that spread was
amongst sailors during the late 17th
century who considered setting sail on
any Friday to be a bad omen
and given that most people including
Pirates were god-fearing Christians the
13th the 13 relating to the Last Supper
being the night before Jesus died
according to historical hearsay the 13
relating to the Last Supper the night
before Jesus died were there 13 apart
there was Twelve Apostles Plus Jesus
that was 13 if the thirteenth fell in
front well first of all I understand why
did sailors wait until the 1700s they
waited 1,700 years
- 32 years so they waited 1,600 and
[ __ ] 68 years people have been
sailing for [ __ ] ever they were
sailing back in jesus's day right well I
guess there was no [ __ ] social media
so it took a while for the story to get
out I don't know anyways if the 13th
fell on Friday most docks and ports
would be emptied out as sailors believe
this to be the greatest ill omen there
could possibly be and for reason and
reason enough not to work on the day or
get out of bed for that matter it's most
people of that time hung crucifixes over
their bed and believed it to be the
safest place in the house now I'm gonna
say most people didn't do that you know
what I mean I would just say like if
back in the day if TV news existed those
were the people's houses that they would
go to and they would try to scare the
[ __ ] out of everybody about Friday the
[ __ ] 13th but I think they would I
think that there was a lot of [ __ ]
people but back then even back then that
would just like do you find he'll
[ __ ] there was people back then that
said Jesus [ __ ] never happened they were
saying it's a couple pieces of wood it
makes the shape of a cross it's it's
it's not like some holy
could they have imagined there was
plenty of people granted they probably
got a lid on fire if they said some [ __ ]
like that I have no idea so anyways it
sounds pretty basic now but back in the
day people simply didn't know any better
if you fell sick around a Friday you
were unlucky around us around a 13th of
a month also unlucky but the two
together somehow was much worse [ __ ]
ancestors I just lack the information
Jesus Christ what about us were the
smart ones ruining the [ __ ] oceans
the Great Barrier Reef is dead you don't
they didn't [ __ ] call they would have
killed it if they had the [ __ ]
opportunity you know what they're the
same [ __ ] we are right now all right
Canadian bus B header oh you know what I
meant to look this up so did you hear
about this guy who beheaded and ate
another guy and they set free how the
[ __ ] is he allowed free and why wasn't
he executed how do they know he won't
relapse into another murder slash dinner
am I crazy by saying if you murder
someone you should be murdered yourself
well yeah if people didn't lie you know
if there weren't people wrongly
convicted I mean I just I feel like
though if it's beyond a shadow of a
[ __ ] doubt you know if you do some of
the animals kids or if you eat
somebody's head on a bus I would have to
say you know yeah you want to [ __ ]
you want to handle it oh you know I
forgot the [ __ ] before I get in this
[ __ ] I forgot to hike my YouTube page
I'm finally gonna start posting videos
them and start doing tours of cities
again and you can watch all of this on
my YouTube page ww youtube.com slash
user slash Monday morning podcast
youtube.com slash users slash Monday
morning podcast all right let me let me
try to find the link of this [ __ ] guy
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Eaton send me I even I wouldn't
even go about eating a head
um oh this is a different one wait a
second
is it no link to this one what just
happened here oh I do have a link I'm
sorry guys this is usually where I'll
try to hit [ __ ] pause so you don't to
go through the torture of this alright
Garrett is there it is okay here we go
Canadian man who beheaded bus passenger
granted total freedom Winnipeg Manitoba
aka
winter Pegg home of the Jets a Canadian
man who was found not criminally
responsible for beheading and
cannibalizing a fellow passenger on a
Greyhound bus has been granted his
freedom he cuts somebody's head off
[ __ ] ate it and wasn't criminally
responsible well who was Manitoba's
Criminal Code Review Board announced
Friday it will give it is given will
Baker formerly known as Vince Lee well
thanks for [ __ ] up his identity in an
absolute discharge meaning he is no
longer subject to monitoring man who
thought roommate was a zombie pleads
guilty to murder okay what the [ __ ] is
going on in Canada that's a completely
different story there's a rabbit hole I
read that one next Baker a diagnosed
schizophrenic killed Tim McLean a young
carnival worker Jesus Christ see this is
why you never take buses carny workers
schizophrenic s-- it's just you know
you're taking your life in your hands
a young carnival worker who was a
complete stranger to Baker in 2008 a
year later he was found not criminally
responsible due to mental illness
okay MacLaine's mother Carol whatever
has been outspoken against granting
Baker's for her his own mother is saying
don't set this guy free saying there'd
be no way to ensure he continued to take
his meds she declined comment
you know in a post on Facebook Friday's
saying I have no words
Baker was initially kept in a secure
wing of a psychiatric hospital was given
more freedom every year he's been living
on his own and Winnipeg apartment since
November but was still subject to
monitoring to ensure he took his
medication baker's doctor dude this is
[ __ ] insane you let a head eater go
free I don't know dude do you think that
they should kill people who are mentally
insane I mean what are you gonna do you
gonna stick him in a room and beat him
for instance Flintstone vitamins for a
select alright man who thought roommate
was a zombie pleads guilty to murder
these are all just mentally ill people
here man a 38 year old man who said he
beat his roommate to death because he
thought she was a zombie pleaded no
contest to second-degree murder now I'm
sitting that one or maybe he just beat
her to death now he's just trying to act
like he's [ __ ] insane a guy entered
the plea Friday in the strangling and
beating death of 35 year old Jennifer
Lopez not the same I want obviously the
Kansas City Star reporter Wallace told
police he had fall asleep after taking a
methamphetamine court documents said he
began beating Lopez when she woke up
because he thought she was a zombie he
told police he kept being lopez until
something made him stop wow this is not
a funny podcast anymore now is it should
you be murdered if you murdered somebody
I think without a [ __ ] doubt if they
know you did it and yeah yeah no I mean
I saw you know I saw it so I don't want
to say what this [ __ ] person did to a
kid but the kid died and like I was just
like why is that person still walking on
the earth there's definitely times where
I feel that and I don't think that that
makes us as bad as they are but prison
is a big business so you know they want
that [ __ ] guy in a Cell all right
Ministry of Truth
hey there Billy hey there Billy of
Rights oh I'm sorry guys I'm so [ __ ]
jet lag to this podcast is really just
[ __ ] lag in here dragon I should say
lots of people are comparing Trump to
Hitler but back in December Obama tried
to quietly pass a bill that would allow
the government yeah I saw this have
jurisdiction over news and outgoing
information on all channels ie TV
internet radio that includes you you can
read the fine print in the article below
also [ __ ] all the people listening who
haven't read the legislation but are
already up in arms because it goes
against who they cheer for amen to that
amen to that everybody's like like last
night all these [ __ ] guys at this
[ __ ] award show everybody trashed and
Donald Trump nobody brings up the fact
that Obama basically signed something
that was gonna implement an incredible
level of [ __ ] censorship like they're
they're basically going to decide what
is real news and what is fake news I
mean I'd like to think because I openly
admit that I don't read and the [ __ ]
that I say it's just [ __ ] absurd that
I would be you know exempt but who knows
but like people with blue ties do this
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] time and that's
that's what kills me about people who
wear red ties and watch Fox News and the
Hollywood people like they just cannot
see the [ __ ] although they only see
it's like it's like listening to us a
fanatic Red Sox and Yankee fan yeah I
mean you know giving each other's [ __ ]
for buying titles and [ __ ] abusing
steroids and it's like no we both did it
we both did it we shouldn't hang our
heads in shame collectively all right
let me see if I can find this this RI I
don't really even want to [ __ ] read
this because this is just so [ __ ]
let's see today I've signed into law s
dot 2 943 the National Defense
Authorization Act for the fiscal year
2017 this Act authorizes fiscal year
2017 appropriations principally for the
Department of Defense in the Department
of Energy national security programs
finds vital benefits for military
personnel families okay blah blah blah
blah blah blah and where do we get to
the yeah dude I can't read all of this I
can't read all of this on a [ __ ] this
will take me [ __ ] three hours to read
out of this but this would have to be a
part of a miniseries for me to read all
of this okay we hear some [ __ ] in
bold the first priority is developing a
whole-of-government strategy for
countering the foreign propaganda and
disinformation being waged waged against
us and our allies by our enemies now
that reads great but it's basically you
know they want yeah listen to our
propaganda not their [ __ ] propaganda
you know our version of what's going on
is right and their version is wrong
we're all fallible we're all [ __ ]
human beings but we don't make mistakes
they do so I don't know it just gets
back to all of that [ __ ] and you know it
sorry you're never gonna solve any even
everybody starts [ __ ] screaming at
each other and if you ever bring up
something like that people call you a
socialist and tell you to get the [ __ ]
out of the country if you if you would
ever even remotely suggest that this
government would ever [ __ ] let they
all lie to that [ __ ] people
oh god they'll shut up okay dear Billy
beer thighs forgive my poor English well
defecting come up Billy beer thighs in a
[ __ ] second language is pretty
amazing so I I think your English is
[ __ ] great I am a native Berliner but
I have family across Germany one of my
female cousins was harassed on the way
to work by some people who are different
I don't want to I do not want to say
just a different race or religion but
also a different way of thinking they
are not native to Germany and are not
acclimating well to Western life I am
NOT a racist and I find the issues very
sensitive but I believe that reality has
to play a part in one's objective view
I'm not against refugees or anyone
displaced because of terrible political
and military situations but
so have a new opinion because of my
cousin she is okay but had 19 stitches
in the back of her neck and head from a
bottle thrown at her because she was a
woman walking alone at night this is not
the first time this has happened in her
town that was good enough to show good
graces to refugees if countries are
going to let people in they have to at
least be okay with women having certain
rights should they not forget about
religion or release that's just good and
bad i think am i a bad person for
becoming a more cautious person when it
comes to refugees thank you and cheers
on your new child no not at all I mean a
lot of that and also people's prejudice
because you're German
they're gonna [ __ ] think a certain way
but like you know if one of the elements
that comes into play is that from
wherever these other people are from
that a woman walking alone at night is
suggesting that she's [ __ ] I don't
know I don't know what loose or having
sex or whatever the [ __ ] it is that's
gonna make him throw a goddamn bottle
like how do you not address that and
also to me he's like what kind of a
[ __ ] person you know when I go to
another country like whatever I see I
just go oh I guess that's how they do it
over here I don't think like you know
well I'm from someplace else and this is
the way we do it so I'm gonna act like
we're still in my country I think that's
ignorant but never underestimate the
power of religion you know when people
really get into it when they really
[ __ ] get into it I you know there's
there's something where your brain goes
on like autopilot and you just let
religion make decisions for you and
rational thought kind of goes out the
[ __ ] window and you just start
breaking one commandment after another
like you tell me one religion out there
if you can find it in whatever book it
is that you read that say it's that says
it's [ __ ] okay to throw a [ __ ]
bottle at a woman
walking alone at night I mean shouldn't
you give me if you think it's you should
have walked her home if you were
concerned about like I don't know I
don't understand like well yeah one of
the things I think refugees should like
if I [ __ ] I say that this country goes
to complete [ __ ] and there's a big war
and all of a sudden they're hunting down
[ __ ] bald redheads and I need to seek
political asylum or some [ __ ] in another
country when I go there the first thing
I'm gonna do is try to learn the [ __ ]
language and then I'm gonna try to
figure out okay how do they do [ __ ] over
here you don't I mean so I don't [ __ ]
offend anybody and so I don't get the
[ __ ] kicked out of me but I would say
the type of people that throw a bottle
like that you know they're also the kind
of people that if they were in higher up
in a corporate thing that they would be
pilfering the coffers as they say or
whatever like there's just certain
people out there that just they're not
good people there's certain people that
are just not smart people that's one of
the [ __ ] problems with human beings is
there's a lot of mouth-breathing morons
and when you accept a bunch of refugees
you know you're gonna get some [ __ ]
super smart people all the way down to
mouth-breather morons I don't think
you're yeah why wouldn't you be more
cautious when it came to refugees if
something like that happened I mean now
having said that within your own country
you also have neo-nazis you know what I
mean so you know if you suggesting
getting rid of all refugees then you
should also do something about neo-nazis
so the hard [ __ ] thing when people go
to a new country is they don't look like
the people that are there so they stick
out like a [ __ ] sore thumb and people
stop looking at them as human beings
they just look at him in as one giant
group whereas if you look at a [ __ ]
neo-nazi he's still a [ __ ] white dude
I'm assuming you're white German right
and you're like that guy he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I mean
you're just looking at him like he
joined a stupid
despite the fact that those people can
do some really horrific [ __ ] to so but I
don't think you know you're a bad person
for becoming more cautious but I would
also remain open-minded that there's
going to be some really great people
that we're lucky enough to get out of
those bad situations and that's the hard
part the easy thing is to just say [ __ ]
all of these people and you know that's
that's the basic let's sit down and eat
some Fritos and cake or you can actually
do the crunches in your cardio and
actually try to look at people as
individuals now having said that when
the Sun Goes Down at night all bets are
off you have to look at people you know
the most cautiously as cautiously as you
possibly can cuz I guarantee you that
even if they had a [ __ ] rule about
that during the day if there was a bunch
of people walking around they the
chances of them doing that during the
day would have been much less so uh
sorry that happened to you one of your
cousins I hope it doesn't turn you into
a hateful person you seem like you're
trying to be measured I don't know but
it would suck if you became another
hateful person because it's just gonna
add fuel to all of this blue tie red
ties [ __ ] alright dear Billy Butkus on
Valentine's Day my ex whom I love people
who know how to use whom you know who
and whom I've looked up the definition
[ __ ] a hundred times I believe I've
read it on this podcast I still for the
life of me cannot figure it out on
Valentine's Day my ex whom I had been
dating for three years came to my job at
a bar with a new much younger date sat
with her for hours and proceeded to get
a cab home with her my co-workers
obviously told me and I was devastated
well that's why he did it
we've been broken up for two and a half
months and it was a really tough breakup
I know I deserve better but I feel like
he's driving me out of a small town that
I generally love this isn't the first
time he's made a public show with a
woman
with women at this point I just want to
want to move and start over what it
should take my take is that you you're a
lucky woman that you you didn't hit your
wagon to someone that's that [ __ ]
petty then yeah I don't yeah I'd like
that like that's I just like the way you
described it I look at that guy as
though he's pathetic
and I feel like and I feel bad for the
woman that he brought there because I
feel like he was barely listening to her
and pretending to be smiling having a
good time as he was trying to look
around to see if he could catch you I
mean he basically went out of his way to
hurt you I mean obviously when you
you're gonna break up with somebody
there's gonna be that awful pain because
usually somebody wants that the other
person doesn't so it's bad enough that
that went down now if you dumped him but
I feel like if you dumped him you
wouldn't be that upset about it and you
did say it was really tough so what I
would say is happy to yourself a
celebratory glass of [ __ ] wine
whatever your poison is that you didn't
marry this [ __ ] and I don't know I think
at some point I mean if you really love
be a shame if you if you really love
living where you're at that you would
move just because some shallow [ __ ] is
bringing some woman that over that I
mean he obviously does not give a [ __ ]
about that one because I'll tell you
this if that guy in two-and-a-half
months
found the one and found true love list
petty [ __ ] with you would not even be an
issue so maybe a new way of looking at
it is feeling bad for the woman that
he's with because he's wasting her time
and I mean I can guarantee you she has
no idea who you are and if she does then
the two [ __ ] psychos that deserve
each other
that should both be sterilized because
they're gonna make an evil baby so there
you go that's what you walked away from
but as far as like you know at this
point you want to move and start over it
all depends on what you got going on in
your town that's a pretty big move you
know let a few days go by see if you
feel that again and just just really
focus on the type of person that would
do something like that to really just go
out of your way to hurt somebody that's
I've heard a bunch of people my life but
to like go out of your [ __ ] way like
that's like the deaths like the
difference between first-degree and
second-degree continets there whereas
you know second-degree it's just
spontaneously happens you know you guys
got all this history and he just says
something [ __ ] horrible or starts
chatting up some chick there at the bar
but to [ __ ] sit there and like
methodically plan it out like that that
guy's a [ __ ] psycho and
congratulations to you that he's done
your [ __ ] life anymore
yeah and don't [ __ ] with this food
that's a petty thing - that's bad karma
[ __ ] all that all right that's the
podcast for this week thank you every
for listening and thank you for the
writers guild for letting me be a
presenter actually he really had a good
time once once I got once I got out
there I had a good time but other than
that I was like freaking out like what
the [ __ ] am I doing here and also please
check out my youtube page like I said
I'm really gonna start posting videos
and all that [ __ ] up there maybe I'll
take a couple of I'll do a video or
something at the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit some backstage [ __ ] or something
like that and once again my YouTube page
is youtube.com slash user slash Monday
morning podcasts and as always if you'd
like to donate to this podcast
any time you gotta buy some [ __ ] you
don't need it on Amazon just go to my
website bill burr com click on the
podcast page you'll see the Amazon link
you click on that it takes you there I
get credit for driving traffic there
whatever you buy doesn't cost you any
extra money amount of money they kick me
a little bit of cash for allegedly
driving traffic but you're gonna [ __ ]
go there anyways if you want to do it
cool that I get it alright go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check in on you on
on Thursday
husband and he's like sitting there
sipping tea with the the wife and